[Musique]
c'est une horrible petite affaire
pour la fille aux cheveux de souris je suis
au chrome de mary un jour mais ta
maman
et elle lui ont dit d'aller écouter
jeune femme mais un ami est
introuvable donc  comment es-tu devenu un coup si chaud en
fait tu marches à travers l'histoire je suis un
showman c'est ce que je suis censé faire
pour les sièges avec la vue la plus claire
et elle est accrochée au grand écran sais-
tu qui je suis ouais tu sais  savoir qui est
ma petite amie robert scheissen
barbra streisand sam sable ouais comme du
sable comme l'océan comme du sable surdimensionné
non séchez du sable du sable
mais le film est une boule de selle c'est la
foi
notre rhodes nous a emmené ici
tu veux vraiment voir mes seins
puis-je  touchez-
les à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est bizarre que je traîne tout le temps avec
Gary et ses amis de 15 ans
[Musique]
je ne vais pas oublier
tout comme tu n'oublieras pas  moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
action
[Musique]
bonjour
toi